les riverains s'en réjouissent les
commerçants un peu moins bras panon a
retrouvé son calme depuis l'extension de
la quatre voies du coup on petit
retrouver à pied les traces de son passé
un passé auquel la commune doit son nom
mais les panonnais l'ont-il encore en
mémoire
pourquoi ça s'appelle bras panon du jeu
du jeu super pour nous parce que c'est
stuart de bras la rivière du mât il
arrivait de roche bras panon patache
habite bois panneaux mais je connais pas
le son qui avaient des riches pour prier
veillette c'est la famille panneaux j'ai
connu un peu plus haut
bras-panon doit vraisemblablement son
nom à l'un des fils d'auguste un panneau
des bassins résidant à l'époque au
lieu-dit liberia et 4e époux de
françoise châtelain de clergy surnommée
la grand-mère des créoles
la légende dit aussi qu'alors qu'il dit
limitait le domaine du sieur des forges
gouverneur de bourbon banon fit une
chute dans le cours d'eau d'où le nom de
bras panne
en tout cas bras panon resté plus d'un
siècle plus tard une localité dépendante
de saint-benoît et de saint-andré une
première demande de séparation du
territoire de bras panon de celui de
saint benoît auprès de sarda garriga en
1850 resta sans réponse en 1880 charles
dureau de vos comptes second
propriétaire sucrier de liberia le
demande at une seconde fois mais ce
n'est que deux ans plus tard quel accéda
au statut de commune le bourg disposait
déjà de son église et s'attelait à la
construction de son collège
la rue des limites et la fontaine ils
marquèrent l'artère principale séparant
les grandes propriétés terriennes côté
montagne des modeste case des
travailleurs en bord de mer catherine
sucrière si implantaire attirés par les
immenses domaine sucrier qui
remplaçaient peu à peu les champs de
café bras panon c'est aussi et surtout
fait une image grâce à la culture de la
vanille dès les années 1840
elle en reste aujourd'hui la capitale